hard work and having a passion for what
you can do can take you a long way in
your career but for many women in the
hotel or restaurant field the odds of
them making it as far as their male
counterparts aren't as good but there is
an effort to change those odds and it's
happening in the dining room the
classroom and the kitchen
maybe i can do the new rainbow trout
stuffed and be great chef gina marinelli
is one of a handful of women recently
nominated for a james beard award one of
the highest honors a chef can receive
when i first started a female executive
chef that didn't exist it's still a
rarity less than seven percent of head
chefs and restaurant owners nationwide
are women seven percent marinelli worked
her way from dishwasher to owner with
this motto that's the thing i always
want people to see is the hardest
working chef not the hardest working
female chef women in the industry have
not been treated the same as men for a
very long time restaurateur jolene
menina realized getting a seat at the
table means working harder smarter and
together how you doing nicole so she
helped launch the women's hospitality
initiative to get more women in
leadership roles both in front and back
of the house to give them the tools give
them some support find mentors for them
you know to find realize you know what
they're capable of doing to that end a
16-week course is now offered at
specialty schools across the country
aptly named women in hospitality
leadership each week dr lisa kane
features a different speaker who shares
their journey we've had celebrity chefs
speak in our class
and they talk about the challenges
they've had so if they've been able to
overcome them you can too there are lots
of challenges when it comes to salary
and titles the castel project released
its 2022 industry report women are
slowly gaining ground and hotel company
leadership now holding one ceo or
president title for every 10 men at the
management director levels women are one
in three florida international
university tracks its chaplain school
graduates we can tell you that men are
earning 91
hundred dollars in hospitality jobs
where women are making seventy three
thousand five hundred i think that's
what the beauty in this class is is it
generates awareness and the more aware
we are of our shortcomings the more we
can work to correct them like many other
industries several things need to happen
increasing pay transparency and
expanding paid medical and family leave
are just a start to evening out the
playing
field now dr kane has been pleasantly
surprised that a number of men are
taking that college course as well
making them aware early in their career
about the title and the salary disparity
and hopefully they can be part of the
solution when it comes to hiring and
placing women in executive positions